Transcriptor: Yonara Anastacio
Revisor: Penny Martínez
¡Hola!
¿Cómo están? ¿Todo bien?
¡Qué bueno verlos!
Ya sé que están muy emocionados
por empezar la clase,
pero antes quiero presentarles
a un nuevo compañero.
Él es Rodo.
¿No es tierno?
Rodo va a estar aquí ayudándonos
por si nos quedamos dormidos,
¿verdad, Rodo?
(Sonido de muñeco de goma)
Bueno, así es como suelo empezar
mis clases con mis alumnos de cinco años.
¡Qué va!, es mentira.
Lo hago con los chicos
de la facultad de quinto de ingeniería.
Ya sé que esto suena un poco extraño.
Pero, ¿saben una cosa?
¿Dónde está escrito que un docente
tiene que ser una persona huraña
gruñona, cascarrabias
y con el ceño fruncido?
Bueno, igual está escrito en algún lado.
Pero yo no estudié pedagogía,
sino todo lo contrario, ingeniería.
Y bueno, esto es lo que hay.
De hecho, ahora que me pongo a pensar,
fue muy accidental la forma
en la que empecé a dar clases.
Estaba un día por aquí, por la facultad,
caminando por los pasillos,
y escuché de una nueva cátedra electiva
que recientemente se estaba incluyendo.
Y resulta que los temas que estaban dando
ahí eran temas de mi interés,
de mi conocimiento.
Con lo que me metí de cabeza en las clases
y empecé a escuchar cómo lo daban.
Y resulta que me pareció interesante
y me pareció que podía contribuir.
Un día me acerqué a los profesores
y les pregunté si podía ver algunos temas.
Me dijeron que sí.
Y así empecé hace ya
unos cinco años más o menos,
así que mi camino docente recién empieza
y aún tengo muchísimo camino por delante.
Pero algo que nunca dejé
es mi paso por las aulas,
en mi rol de alumno.
La verdad es que he estudiado de todo,
desde aprender a tocar el ukelele
a bailar salsa, pasando por karate,
inglés y otras cosas.
Y ahí me encontré con un montón
de docentes espectaculares,
pero también me encontré con varios
que dejaban bastante que desear.
La cuestión es que cuando me tocó a mí
estar en ese rol de docente,
me puse a pensar, a reflexionar
en qué era lo que hacía
que esas clases me gustaran tanto,
qué era lo que me inspiraba.
Y también pensé qué debía evitar.
Tal vez había algunos patrones, algo,
como una especie de fórmula.
Vamos, que nuevamente soy ingeniero.
La cuestión es que ahí encontré
que los mejores docentes
diseñaban cada momento de la clase
pensando y centrándose en el alumno.
Y en función de eso, te contaban
una historia para atraparte
luego, hacían un chiste
para llamar tu atención,
y cuando tenían tu atención,
ya profundizaban en contenidos teóricos.
Notaban cuando te estabas cansando,
a punto de aburrirte,
o ya llegando el hartazgo,
y entonces paraban.
Al volver del recreo
te daban algún ejercicio práctico,
y así podíamos implementar
lo que habíamos visto en la teoría,
darle un sentido y entenderlo.
Y finalmente, terminaban la clase
con una reflexión,
para que nos fuéramos pensando
en todo lo que habíamos visto.
Lamentablemente,
profesores como estos no son usuales.
Lo que nos solemos encontrar,
son personas que hacen un monólogo
bastante monótono y aburrido,
en el que leen una diapositiva.
Lo sé porque yo lo he hecho.
Pero, aparte de eso también
suelen quejarse o molestarse
cuando uno les cuestiona
lo que están dando.
También nos pasa que nos impulsan
a estudiar a través del miedo.
“Toma nota, esto va en el examen”,
suelen decir.
La cuestión es que estamos en el siglo XXI
con un modelo educativo del siglo XVIII,
y tanto docentes como alumnos
nos juntamos en un lugar,
donde los docentes somos
los que tenemos el saber, el conocimiento,
somos dueños de la verdad.
Y vamos a enseñar.
Y los alumnos están ahí
más de forma pasiva.
El lugar donde nos dicen quédate quieto,
no hagas ruido, molestes o rompas nada
Trata de pasar el año
y, si aprendes, bueno,
es un efecto secundario
de haber estado ahí.
Y a todo esto, además,
tenemos que sumarle la pandemia.
Algo que cambió todo
de la noche a la mañana.
Ya era difícil dar clases presencialmente.
Imagínense, si además de eso,
tuvimos que acostumbrarnos
y aprender a usar herramientas
de la noche a la mañana.
Un verdadero caos.
Esto es un lío.
Y, ¿qué pasó?
Pues tuvimos que hacernos preguntas,
que empezar a reflexionar.
A decir: “¿Cómo y con qué
herramientas vamos a conectarnos?”
“¿Cómo vamos a hacer las actividades
que hacíamos en clase?
en las que ellos estaban ahí juntos,
pero que ahora es a través
de este nuevo medio.
¿Cómo vamos a hacer los exámenes?”
Y ahí la pregunta era
porque iban a copiar.
Y ¿cómo hacemos
para vigilarlos y controlarlos?
Fíjense.
La falta de confianza docente-alumno.
Y también la falta
de hacernos otras preguntas.
Como que tal vez haya algo diferente
para validar los conocimientos
de un alumno más allá
de un examen escrito,
en donde el profesor te tenga que vigilar.
Y todo esto me recuerda
una frase que dijo Nietzsche,
que dice algo así como:
“Uno tiene que tener un caos interior,
para poder poner en el mundo
una estrella danzante”.
Bueno, el caos ya lo tenemos, y de sobra.
¿Quieren un poco?
Tomen. Ahí va.
La cuestión es que tenemos que poner
en el mundo de la educación una estrella.
Y tratar de hacerla brillar
lo mejor que podamos.
No va a ser fácil, pero hemos pasado
por un montón de dificultades
en este último año y medio.
Y dentro de todo, las hemos superado.
Hemos aprendido nuevas herramientas,
cambiado nuestros equipamientos
y nos hemos formado.
Así que tenemos un mundo
de oportunidades ahí por explorar.
Podemos tomar todos esos conocimientos
y empezar a rediseñar una experiencia
de aprendizaje mixta,
tomando lo mejor de la presencialidad
y de la virtualidad,
dando clases sincrónicas,
es decir en tiempo real,
con contenido sincrónico.
Es más, los impulso a que piensen,
a que se imaginen un mundo
en el que levantamos las fronteras
y las barreras creadas por la distancia.
Y en función de eso podemos conectar
a los mejores alumnos,
talentos y mentes,
para que aprendan entre ellos.
Y en este punto
Uds. se estarán preguntando:
“Frank, ¿me puedes contar algún método,
herramienta, algo, o darme un consejo?”
Pues ya me gustaría a mí saberlo.
Yo tampoco tengo respuesta
a esas preguntas.
Pero a lo que sí los puedo invitar
es a que intenten, prueben, experimenten
y a que vuelvan al rol de alumno
y aprendan de sus propios errores.
Porque en definitiva, lo que tenemos aquí
es la posibilidad de cambiar la educación,
de transformarla para siempre.
No importa si las clases son virtuales,
presenciales o mixtas,
lo que importa es que podemos
llevar vida a las aulas
y podemos llevar la educación
a un nuevo nivel de excelencia,
con otra calidad y con otro impacto
que nunca antes hemos visto.
En definitiva.
Llegó la hora de despertarse.
(Hace sonar la pelota de goma).